معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام
اذا بعد ليله داميه في معظم مناطق جنوب
قطاع غزه والوسط ايضا كيف يبدو الوضع
الان الوضع هو استمرار للقصف الاسرائيلي
القصف مستمر لا سياما في خانيونس حيث نفذت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه قبل قليل
غاره على خانيونس لم يعرف بعد تفاصيل هذه
الغاره لا سما في ظل انقطاع الاتصالات
لليوم السادس على توالي وانقطاع الاتصالات
يعني انقطاع الاتصالات ما ايضا ما بين
المواطنين وما بين طواقم الدفاع المدني
وطواقم الاسعاف وبالتالي لا يستطيعون حتى
الابلاغ عن وجود جثامين او حتى وجود
اصابات جراء هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه
ينتقلون او ينقلون الجرحى الى المستشفيات
ومن ثم تتوجه طواقم الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع
المدني الى المكان المستهدف وهذا بالتاكيد
ياخذ وقتا طويلا وربما يودي بحياه العشرات
من الشهداء الذين يصابون العشرات من
الجرحى الذين يصابون باصابات خطيره ويبقون
في تلك المناطق المستهدفه الجيش
الاسرائيلي كثف من غاراته على خانيونس
جنوب قطاع غزه وفي محيط مستشفى ناصر
انسحبت الدبابات الاسرائيليه بالفعل لكن
الغارات الاسرائيليه مازالت متواصله القصف
المدفعي ايضا ما زال متواصلا وربما في تلك
المنطقه نبش الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد دخول
الدبابات وتقدمها في محيط مستشفى ناصر
المقابر القريبه من هذا المست المستشفى
وهناك دمار كبير في المنازل المدنيه
الفلسطينيه انتشل سبع شهداء لكن عمليات
البحث والتمشيط ما زالت جاريه من قبل
طواقم الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع المدني لكن
ايضا الغارات مستمره كذلك على مدينه غزه
وعلى وسط القطاع على مدينه غزه القصف
يتمركز في المناطق الغربيه مخيم الشاطئ
ومنطقه انصار وهذه المناطق باتت تتعرض الى
قصف عنيف منذ ثلاثه ايام ربما اشتد القصف
على مدينه غزه حيث باتت الطائ ئرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه تقصف المدينه ايضا
وشمال القطاع الدبابات الاسرائيليه اصلا
تقدمت من عده محاور من محور الشجاعيه
وكذلك من جباليا وبيت لاهيه وبيت حنون بعد
ان كانت انسحبت بشكل كامل من تلك المناطق
وتمركزت على على الحدود الشماليه والحدود
الشرقيه لكنها ما عادت ان ان تقدمت بعض
الشيء بعض عده كيلومترات وباتت تطلق
القذائف باتجاه هذه المناطق منطقه زمو في
المناطق الشرقيه لجبال ايضا مناطق جباليه
وبيت لاهيه وبيت حنون وجميعها محاذيا
للحدود الشماليه لقطاع غزه وايضا بيت حنون
للحدود الشرقيه كذلك القصف مستمر على عده
احياء ما بين فينه واخرى تستهدف الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه
في مدينه غزه واستهدفت عده منازل خلال
الايام الماضيه في الصبره وفي حي الزيتون
وفي حي تل الهواء وعندما نتحدث عن مدينه
غزه نحن نتحدث عن المدينه التي دمرت اغلب
احيائها وبالتالي
المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه المتواجده في
تلك المدينه هي منازل قليله عدد قليل من
هذه المنازل مازالت قائمه ربما طالها
الضرر لكن لم يطالها التدمير بشكل كامل
وبالتالي الناس تلجا الى هذه المنازل
للاحتماء والبقاء في ظل هذا البرد القارس
وعدم وجود اماكن تلجا اليها في مدينه غزه
ورغم كل ذلك يستهدفها الجيش الاسرائيلي
يستهدف ايضا مراكز الايواء ويوقع الشهداء
والجرحى القصف ايضا مستمر في مناطق وسط
القطاع لا سما مخيم المغازي مخيم البريج
وكذلك مخيم النصيرات وهذه المناطق تتعرض
الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
خاصه بان الجيش الاسرائيلي انسحب الى
الحدود الشرقيه من مخيم المغازي ومخيم
البريج لكنه ما زال يسيطر بالنار على هذه
المخيمات ويقصف المنازل في تلك المناطق ال
عدد من الشهداء والجرحى نقلوا ايضا الى
مستشفى اب الشهداء الاقصى في في دير البلح
وسط القطاع من جراء هذه الاستهدافات من
قبل الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ومن قبل
المدفعيه هناك ايضا طائرات كواد كابتر
تطلق النار على المواطنين لا سما في
المناطق الشماليه في لمخيم النصيرات نحن
نتحدث عن عن منطقه المغرا منطقه مدينه
الزهراء ارض المفتي المخيم الجديد في مخيم
النصيرات وجميعها تتعرض للقصف وايضا
طائرات كواد كابتر تحلق في تلك المناطق
وتطلق النار على المواطنين شكرا جزيلا لك
من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت